well you're a skeptic parties and the
far-right have enjoyed gains right
across mainland Europe his Ashish Joshi
- tell us about it Ashish thanks Dermot
there's a theme across Europe this
morning in France the far-right National
Front beat competition from opposition
conservatives and the ruling socialists
to lead the vote marine lepen
anti-immigration anti-eu parties secured
more than a quarter of the ballots cast
as voters registered a protest against
austerity and mass unemployment Greece
saw the radical left sir it's a party
topped the polls ahead of the country's
two traditional ruling parties sir it
says euro scepticism is based mainly on
their opposition to EU bailout and
Greece also elected at least two members
from the extremist Golden Dawn party who
took nearly 10 percent of the vote a
third of the party's leadership are in
prison on charges of running a criminal
organisation
Denmark's anti-immigration people's
party benefited from the surge in
nationally support winning 27% of the
vote and doubling its number of MEP s
from two to four in Germany alternative
for Deutschland a party that's only a
year old won at least six seats with 7%
of the vote they want Germany to stop
using the euro but deny that they're
anti Europe but after a change in the
law that means fringe parties don't have
to get a minimum of three percent of the
vote the country's National Democratic
Party has won its first seat Germany 16
states vast a top court to ban the party
because they claim it's anti-semitic